so last week or the week before we
covered Donald Trump calling on a
Kurdish journalist by saying mr. Kurd
and of course the Kurds being an ethnic
group saying mr. Kurd ask your question
would be like saying mr. Jew or mr.
black and it didn't really make any
sense but what is a great thing that
came from that is that it reminded us of
my interview with Steven Mansfield about
the Kurds and Kurdistan and how the
Kurds fit into the future of the Middle
East which we did back in November of
2014 and what's amazing about this
interview is that it would seem like one
of those interviews that appeals to a
slice of our audience really
significantly and a lot of people just
don't care about it but this interview
ended up doing extraordinarily well
hundreds of thousands of views on
YouTube if not more and for not more
than half a million at this point and it
is a really fascinating interview and
Steven Mansfield is excellent on this
topic of the Kurds so that's where we
are starting this week in terms of
classic interview with my interview from
November of 2014
Steven Mansfield about the Kurds and
Kurdistan I'm joined today by Steven
Mansfield who's the author of the
miracle of the Kurds a remarkable story
of hope reborn in northern Iraq and I
think a great place to start Steven is
your book focuses on northern Iraq but
it would be important I think for the
audience to understand the Kurds as a
group beyond just Iraq so let's start
there who are the Kurds well it's
probably most important to know that the
Kurds are non Arab people who consider
themselves the descendants of the
ancient Medes people probably know this
term best from their Bibles here the
laws of the Medes and the Persians that
we read about in the Old Testament and
they are a unique people in the Middle
East having lived largely in the
mountains those who just like them
called them the hillbillies of the
Middle East but they're they're far more
progressive than that they have strong a
strong sense of tradition a strong sense
of belonging a strong sense of culture
and their graciousness their hospitality
combined with their warrior code they're
sort of poet warriors some have said
makes them distinct in the Middle East
they I think it's also important for
people to know that they
have been mistreated time and again
though they though they are certainly
large enough to warrant their own
homeland their region up in the north
around the Zagros Mountains over lay
parts of Turkey parts of Iran parts of
Syria and of course Iraq has has not
been you know they the boundaries have
not been drawn in all the treaties of
Europe after World War one in more
recent times so they could have their
own homelands so they've ended up being
a minority people amongst many of the
nations in the Middle East and that of
course is their historic complaint
what's brought them to international
attention in recent decades of course is
Saddam's atrocities against them so we
have this group that is largely it's
correct to say it's it's mostly a Sunni
Muslim group correct that's correct we
have this group that has there they're
predominantly living in specific areas
of a variety of countries as you've
mentioned one of the most interesting
things to me about the Kurds is if we go
back to the Ottoman Empire right we have
these circumstances where in a lot of
the recent conversations on corporate
media including the kind of kerfuffle on
the Bill Maher program one of the things
that I think was missing from the
analyses that was being made by
everybody was that before the Ottoman
Empire pre dissolution of the Ottoman
Empire the Muslim people were much more
united as a people so to speak and that
now you see very significant differences
between Muslims in different parts of
that part of the world something similar
has happened with the Kurds has it not
where they are no longer even though
they all I guess we could say share this
general desire for for a land that is
their own they are not really a unified
group in any sense of the word
well the Kurds do have their divisions
they've had an embarrassing civil war
right at a time they might have been
taking their control of their own
destiny in their hands back down just
after the no-fly zone in the early 90s
and of course what really has caused
them grief in recent years is that so
much of what they have suffered even
during the Saddam years was a result of
mistreatment by their Islamic brothers
i-i sat with the senior mullah of
Kurdistan not too long ago and he told
me that he had no intention of letting
the more extremist kind of Islam that
had done them damage for so many years
into his region the Kurds are very
moderate they have women on their
Supreme Court that women commanding
Peshmerga troops of female entrepreneurs
there's a Christian department in the
KRG the Kurdish regional government so
they actually have a government devoted
to Christians devoted to his ease
they're very moderate are very open to
other religious expressions but you're
absolutely right they're suspicious of
the surrounding Islamic world because
that world has conspired against them so
much in recent decades can you talk to
us a little bit Stephen about you know I
think one of the most important things
right now
because of all of the misinformation
that is that that is often spread about
the so called inherent violence of any
any population that is Muslim I want to
talk a little bit about the Kurds in
that context so we can not kind of
caricature them or lump them in with any
group they don't deserve to be in my
research I came across what I would call
numerous individual or anecdotal
instances stories of kidnappings by
Kurds violence against Christian
minorities by Kurds etc contextualize it
for us in terms of what can we look at
these incidents as isolated in some way
and if so why or what does it really
tell us about the Kurds well anyone
who's making the case that the Kurds are
an angelic people are making a foolish
case this is this is a people group of
as many as 30 million people will there
be crimes will there be religious
bigotry
will there be violence of course there
will on the whole though what's
appealing about the Kurds is their
moderation are the few very very few
killings that took place once they had
their affairs in their own hands and
they were protected from Saddam I would
never try to make the case that there
are people you know free of violence
free of religious bigotry in fact one of
the things I put in my book that
concerns me is that they share with the
rest of the Muslim world in the Middle
East portion of the most of the world
anyway a rise in honor killings
particularly in the rural
you have you know women who will go to
the cities go to universities learn sort
of Western ways or looser ways than
perhaps their rural context would want
religiously and there are honor killings
so so to speak of course I would
consider them dishonor killings but you
understand that's the term that's used
yes and so this this concerns me greatly
so it's wise that we've set this in
context no one is saying that the Kurds
are without some of the violence some of
the persecution I've had Christian
friends assassinated in in Kurdish
cities the difference perhaps is that
the Kurdish government came to those of
us and apologized and said this is rare
statistically it was rare so you do have
a more moderate slightly more peaceful
people than you do in the surrounding
area but again no one's claiming that
they're angels and there's they're
subject to the same religious extremism
as other peoples with regard to the
current battle against Isis and the the
possibilities of any kind of alliance
between the u.s. and the Kurds how do
you see the Kurds fitting into this
current incursion that involved Isis
well the Kurds are the most effective
fighting force on the ground against
Isis what's amazing about them in my
view is that they still see themselves
as a US ally despite the fact that the
u.s. government has betrayed them time
and again in fact one of the worst
gassings in human history happened in
1988 in a city called Halabja and some
of the gas that fell on Halabja was sold
by US companies to saddam time and again
there have been betrayals and yet the
the Kurds see themselves as US allies so
they're willing to fight Isis they want
to fight Isis they understand the threat
of Isis what they need is arms from the
West particularly the US and close air
support but there are very very
effective fighters they've proven this
time and again they have a martial hist
a very strong martial tradition that
goes back pre ottoman times and it
certainly was enhanced during the
Ottoman times they teach their young
from the very beginning to fight you
know to shoot on one foot and then shoot
on the other to develop balance and and
good targeting and what's interesting
about that to me Stephan not to
interrupt is that in many other contexts
hearing about a group that teaches their
children how to fight would be seen as
an incredibly
negative and concerning thing right in
other words in the absence of a
strategic specific that that would make
that an advantage we would say we should
be horrified that there is a group that
is teaching its children how to shoot
guns standing on one foot and this is
what concerns me because time and time
again we've seen the u.s. armed groups
that then we eventually end up fighting
against our own weapons right and and so
what can you tell us about how this
situation if you believe it would be
different why would it be different than
those countless situations the u.s. gets
itself into well I certainly understand
your concern and I I wouldn't lay it
aside at all I think it's valid the
difference perhaps with the Kurds as
they proven themselves time and again
they are not in mating of the nations
they have never missed used what
material was given to them they have
they have no designs no I'm know
imperial designs they they have I guess
the best way to say it is they've proven
themselves again and again whenever you
arm a people you take a risk there's no
question that you you know you may see
those weapons in another context we've
certainly seen that in Afghanistan we've
seen it elsewhere
but if there are any people on the earth
in my view have proven themselves time
and again capable of restraint capable
of using the weapons for the purposes
for which they were given it's the Kurds
and that we're talking about decades now
that they have been a people though they
maintain a martial culture it's not too
unlike you know a father in Alabama
teaching his sons to hunt I mean it's
about it's approximately at that level
we're not talking about militias here
for sixteen year olds or fourteen year
olds but nevertheless yes it's it's
something we would need to watch but I'm
not sure we have any other options right
now we don't want to put us boots on the
ground against Isis Isis is only about
thirty thousand more years of the Kurds
or the Peshmerga are eighty to a hundred
thousand
they just need arms they need strategy
they need close support and I think that
we can defeat Isis so we'll have to you
know we'll have to take that risk I
think as I'm not sure we have any other
options and they're the best investment
that I can see in the region all right
very very interesting and the book is
fascinating to remind everybody we've
been speaking with Steven Mansfield and
the book
the miracle of the Kurds a remarkable
story of hope reborn in northern Iraq
Steven really a pleasure having you on
thank you great to be with you David